he was mad about motor racing and he
when he decided to do a film about it he
talked to his friend George Axelrod and
they agreed that it had to either be a
test pilot or grotto Grand Hotel and
they finally chose Grand Hotel
Steve he saw Steve McQueen at one point
and Steve McQueen wasn't interested in
doing your Grand Hotel and John didn't
get to meet with him because he was off
shooting a film and the producer and he
didn't get along and what happened was
that he sort of he went behind he
decided he was going to make his own
movie ahead of us and it was a very
touch-and-go thing really we would we
felt like spies rushing around John sent
word down from a location for seconds up
the beach in Malibu and sent a little
man down and said call sampie Zarn tell
him to tie up all the circuits and I
said did he send a phone number but
anyway by hook or crook I was able to
say tie up the circuits it was very
exciting I felt like Edward Lewis or
someone and the whole thing was he was
mad about the whole premise but the you
have to realize that the racing
community at the beginning was not happy
to have us were they but they then
realized we were sort of serious and
we're going to just have bumper car time
it was a wonderful wonderful experience
I read the script and I and I love this
script but I knew I'd have trouble
because I don't like to go fast in
anything I mean I'd rather go under 405
and a Conestoga way I know it's not
practical and all that but I do it
actually seemed but I but but the whole
idea and the sound now your dear husband
never knew this this is a secret but I
had earplugs in my ears see what I mean
he would have killed me but I took them
out I know my hair was similar to this
so no install them I couldn't stand the
sound
I couldn't stand everything going so
fast
but I fell in love with Iman song I mean
in the movie but oh he was so charming
and our daughter and the son were over
there they were younger of course and he
really had a thing about our daughter
she's here tonight I won't ask you to
stand up the right her name is the RET
but he had a thing and for years they
correspond 'add and that's okay but the
very last shot correspondents right that
I had with him and so the very last shot
the very last day the very last take and
we finished it and then we had to do
something with a life so we had to do it
again and I was standing next to him and
he was sitting down and he pulls me down
onto his lap and he said Ethan Mellie he
said you are my favorite leading lady
and I wanted to say why did you wait
today to tell me but he was so now
Johnny Frankenheimer had such a job
doing this I don't know how he managed
because all the so many people and so
many cars and the first day I flew to
Brussels and I met the the cast and the
crew and makeup people and everybody and
we were having dinner and someone said
and these are the drivers and I said Oh
which one is my driver Jim Garner is
wonderful in this film and he's a true
Drive in real life he's a driver racer
and evil Don really look more like the
drive a racer because he had these
circles under his eyes as if you've been
wearing the goggles and but he didn't he
didn't he did not like driving or racing
and and Jim would go so fast that Johnny
Frankenheimer said Jim if you don't stop
and go slower you'll not be in this film
cause he goes when the camera